اذا لنعد ونذكر بما حدث في الاجواء
الامريكيه حيث اكتشفت القوات الامريكيه من
طادا تجسس صيني فوق الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وقامت بتتبعه منذ دخوله الى المجال الجوي
الامريكي قبل ايام قادما على ما يبدو من
كندا واضاف المسؤول لان الهدف من المنطاد
هو التجسس ومساره يمر فوق عدد من المواقع
الحساسه لكن المسؤول الامريكيه شاري لان
تاثيره محدود في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباريه كما ذكر ان وزير الدفاع
ورئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الجنرال مارك
ميلي او صياد بعدم اتخاذ اجراء عسكري بسبب
الخطر المحتمل لحطام المنطاد اذا سقط في
مناطق مهوله وفي كندا تحدثت وزاره الدفاع
عن حادث ثاني محتمل مرتبط بمنطاد تجسس
تجسس صيني
واشارت الاتخاذها تدابير لضمان امن مجالها
الجوي
وقال مسؤول عسكري امريكي انه تم تجهيز
مقاتلات من بينها مقاتلات من طراز اف 22
في ولايه مونتانا حيث شوهد من طرد التجسس
الصيني في حال اتخاذ قرار باسقاطه او
تفجيره وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قد
استفسر عن خيارات عسكريه لاسقاط المنطاد
وهو ما نصح البنتاجون بتجنبه لخطره على
المدنيين في غضون ذلك نقلت صحيفه
الامريكيه استدعت القائمه بالاعمال الصيني
في واشنطن بشانه منطاد التجسس واضاف ان
الهدف من الاستدعاء بعث رساله واضحه
لبرجين
وافادت الصحيفه ان الخارجيه الامريكيه
رفضت التعليق بشان ما اذا كانت زياره
الوزيرا توني بلينكن الى بيجيني يومي
الخامس والسادس من الشهر الجاري قد الغيت
بعد الكشف عن منطاد التجسس الصيني وهو ما
تاكد لاحقا